are you applying for jobs and just
struggling to find the motivation to
write your cover letter we've all been
there my name is Martin McGovern and
today I'm going to share with you three
reasons why you should always include a
cover letter with your resume when
applying for your dream job reason
number one ability to express yourself
the resume is a great document but a
good resume is no longer than a page so
in order to fully express yourself and
explain why you're the best person for
the role you definitely want to include
a cover letter to give that further
context reason number two looking
forward or looking back the resume again
it's a wonderful document but it is so
focused on your past you want to be
sharing your aspirations with this
company and explaining why you're going
to be someone who can help them
throughout the future so use your cover
letter to be able to expand on your past
and show where you're going in your
career and reason number three you get
to finally be specific about this role
and this company
resumes are a bit more on the generic
side but in the cover letter you get to
actually reference the roll reference
the company and reference why you are
going to be the best person for the job
let's recap number one you get more
space to express yourself number two you
get to look forward and not just look
back and number three you really get to
get specific about why you're the right
person for this job that's why you want
to include a cover letter every time you
submit your resume in a job application
and as Jayson freed founder of 37signals
once said in an interview to Inc
magazine cover letters say it all they
immediately tell you if someone wants
this job or if they just want any job
thank you for watching if you have any
other questions about the cover letter
or any tips of your own please put them
in the comments and if you know anyone
who is currently looking for a job tag
them and let them know you're thinking
about them we look forward to bringing
you many more videos like this in the
future
and wish you the best of luck in your
job search
[Music]